mia khalifa who is she's an adult film
actress i'm very
pleased to tell you by the way i don't
mean to preen or boast i'm obviously a
miserable sinner
who who you know has done terrible
things in my life just as has every
single person
but i can say with total honesty i have
never seen this woman's work
and i'm very glad because if her uh if
her professional work is anything like
her political commentary
i bet it's not very edifying mia khalifa
decided to take the occasion of the 4th
of july
to criticize and deride the united
states
morning happy 4th of july i just want to
remind you guys on this beautiful
independence day that all america does
is destabilize other countries and then
treat refugees and
immigrants from those destabilized
countries
like second-class citizens and trash so
a very silly commentary first of all
because we only have one legal system
of systemic racism in this country right
and that would be
affirmative action which prioritizes
non-white people it gives an advantage
to non-white people
and disadvantages white people and
asians also so the idea that refugees
and people from say the middle east or
africa
are treated as second-class citizens is
just not as a fact of the law they are
treated much better
than whites and asians there is one
other
system of structural racism that gives
an advantage to some people
that would be our open borders so our
open borders
gives huge immigration priority to latin
americans
instead of other groups from around the
world again though to non-white people
so her argument here completely
ridiculous but then let's take the first
part seriously she said all the united
states does is destabilize other nations
the united states has destabilized other
nations that's true
for instance when barack obama and
hillary clinton decided to uh
lead libya into a revolution that was
probably a bad idea but they did that
when when the united states under obama
and clinton
decided to destabilize egypt by pulling
their support from our long time ally mo
uh no mama gaddafi uh hosni mubarak that
was
probably a mistake so it's true the
united states has destabilized a lot of
parts of the world
destabilized iraq under saddam hussein
some people say that was a good thing to
do but
nevertheless certainly destabilizing
okay
is that first of all is the united
states the only country that does that
of course not
but second of all is that all the united
states does
see what what mia khalifa here is saying
that is
important for a discussion of political
philosophy and never thought i'd say
that statement
is the word all because
it's a matter of framing you remember
the 1619 project
made up a bunch of stuff right the
central thesis of the 1619 project
at the new york times is that the
american revolution was fought to defend
slavery it's just not true it's
completely fictitious
but whatever the times corrects that
seven months later
as i write in my book speechless what
the issue is is not the fact so much as
the framing the 1619 project
comes out and says we want to reframe
american history to put slavery at the
center of it
and so the lie here that mia khalifa is
telling at least in that first sentence
is not that
the united states destabilizes countries
we have we've destabilized plenty of
countries as
have many other countries the lie is
that that's all that we do that's the
center
of the frame for for mia khalifa is that
the united states is this force of evil
that destabilizes countries and then
takes in refugees and treats them poorly
which is
obviously that part is not true but it's
that framing
that's what you've got to say what is
are we celebrating america or are we not
celebrating america
is the fourth of july even our
independence day there's some debate
about that now because we have a second
national independence day the juneteenth
holiday
which you might call critical race
theory day i mean the juneteenth holiday
which was it was a local tradition in
galveston texas it became a national
holiday
because of these radical leftist race
hustlers that
is those were the people who were
pushing for it that was the argument
that they were giving
for the holiday on the floor of congress
and
it's in the very name now the national
independence day of june
on in the bill that that created this
new federal holiday
when they tell you that you've got to
believe them hey hold up
i hope you liked that clip if you did we
got a whole episode america goes through
puberty that's the title of the episode
i'm not just stating that but i am still
it is true
matthew mcconaughey made a good point
head on over ring the bell subscribe
check out the full episode
you can also get it on apple podcast
google play stitcher on the michael
knowles show podcast and you can also
order
my book which hit number one on all
books on amazon thanks to wonderful
readers like you
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i'll see you next time